All right Henry, what should be the topic of my question Tuesday video? Pokemon!  Alice, what should my question Tuesday video be about? Monkey Turtles!
Monkey Turtles‽ Good morning. Hank, it's Tuesday
It's question Tuesday the day that I answer real questions from real nerdfighters about Pokémons and monkey turtles oh, and look: it's a reunion video
We're all here together in the desert
I don't know what monkey turtles are. I also didn't know what a monkey turtle was so I asked Alice and she said it's a
Monkey that turns into a turtle. Right... yeah... right. For why?  Oh, I asked her that and she said for protection
Then I asked Alice how big monkey turtles were and she said 100 big
Big. Well, or not
Right,true. It depends on if it's millimeters. You need to learn units. Talking to Alice is like talking to a not very good AI
She's like a bad chatbot. Yeah, she said to me, "Uncle Hank,
I got this new water bottle" and I said "Is it better than your old water bottle?" and she said "It's pink, the other's purple" like
It's like I asked you a question you answered a different question, right, but you kind of were on the same topic
She's also like a chatbot in that a lot of times if you ask her a question
She'll say "I don't want to talk about that." What is your favorite Pokemon? And why is it Charizard?
It's not Charizard, it's Snorlax, because he's cute and large and powerful. Mine is Andrew. Andrew‽ Yeah.
Have you, have you seen the Andrew Pokemon? Is he a monkey turtle? No, he's just a guy, plays guitar.
What pokemon could best keep a steady job?
Oh, probably Andrew.
Put it in your head: Charizard managing like a Wendy's and if the like the grill breaks, he's just (flame noise)
on all the burger. Oh my God, he can cook the burgers! Yeah. Oh wow!
What is the most underrated Pokemon ? Oh, I think the most underrated Pokemon is surfing Pikachu?
I'm gonna go with like the, the wiggle puffed
Jigglypuff? Or... uh...
Spike ladder. Spike ladder, that's a real one.
It isn't? You ask Henry what he wants to be when he grows up, he says "inventor", and then he pauses and says
"Of Pokemon" John? Yes?
How can I be the very best?
Like no one ever was. Come on! If you had to permanently dye your hair a non-natural color. What would it be? Uh, Silver? [ooh]
Well, you're getting there already. I know, I'm on my way!
When I was in college, I thought to myself, I want to have a job where when I turned 40 I can get a mohawk
Mm-Hmm, and now I do! Hey, welcome to Crash Course Biochemistry
It's me your cool teacher Hank with the 40 year old mohawk. [Laughter]
Doesn't all value derive from Humans?
Mmm.... No.
I just want to say for the record. Hank is not taller than I am, It's just that
he is standing on a rock. Well...
I, I was downhill. Hank, what is your favorite adjective to throw in when you wanna spice up a sentence? Spicy.
I don't like that at all. What do you think of that three-point shot hank? Spicy!
I don't want to be like my friends will all be like, yeah, Hank, the one who says spicy all the time
Oh yeah, Hank "Spicy" Green they call him
Oh, shoot. Who would win in a fight between a monkey-turtle and a turtle-monkey?
Oh, definitely a monkey-turtle cos it could turn into a turtle for protection. What is your favourite type of plate?
Oh, uh, for me, it's the, the kind that the Earth's crust is on. Oooo
I mean, those are good. Sometimes you're at a really fancy restaurant and there's a plate on the table before
the food comes out and then they take that plate away. Yes.  And I'm like,WHAT WAS THAT? Right. WHY WAS THAT PLATE THERE?
Yeah, just in case. Explain it to me. It's a just in case plate. Would you rather have C-3PO in your house or R2D2?
R2D2 because like I like whenever I hang out with you I kind of feel like I do have C-3PO in my house
It's true. Hank, what Pokemon do you think looks the most like you?  [barely perceptibly] Oh my god, I don't know.
I don't know either, but I'm excited to find out from my viewers. Like, isn't Mr. Mime the only one that walks on two feet?  Uhh...
Um, I mean. Or like it's vaguely human shaped? I don't know of a greater insult than saying that someone looks like Mr. Mime
We're gonna go keep walking so goodbye friends. Bye. I'll see you now. You want to see our, uh, our
incredibly sophisticated tripod by the way?  It's Hanks wallet...and two rocks
Doo doop!